here's what would happen if you only ate  raw meat well you'd have to cut the raw  meat up into small bite-sized pieces as  human teeth struggle to break down raw  meat  undercooked or raw meat and poultry can  be contaminated with harmful bacteria  like E coli salmonella and yersinia if  meat does have bacteria in it it can  cause diarrhea stomach cramps vomiting  and fever to reduce your chances of  experiencing this you should only eat  locally sourced and organic meats that  haven't been overly processed meat  lovers say that once your body gets used  to eating raw meat you'll get a lot more  nutrients and protein than you would  from the cooked Alternatives however  research shows that eating more than two  grams of protein per kilogram of body  weight daily can cause symptoms of  dehydration nausea irritability headache  and even death so